[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the unbreakable vow we will be touching
on what it is as well as the
repercussions of breaking said vow the
unbreakable vow is a binding magical
contract that connects two parties the
purpose is simple it is to bind your
fellow witch or wizard to a promise the
participants stand opposite each other
and clasp each other's right hand while
a third party almost acts like a
mediator or witness and places the tip
of their want onto the hands of the two
participants the mediator acts almost
like a minister and will begin to state
conditions or responsibilities related
to the vow after stating each condition
of the vow the participant who is to
uphold said responsibilities must have
greased them one by one a great example
of an unbreakable vow is the one that
Snape agreed to with Narcissa Malfoy and
Bellatrix Lestrange in 1996 the
conditions of this vow were to protect
Malfoy from harm while he attempted to
perform a task that Lord Voldemort had
asked him to perform this task was of
course to kill Albus Dumbledore Snape
also agreed to complete the task that
Malfoy was assigned in the event that he
was unable this of course led to the
famous scene in which Snape kills out
was tumbled or however Snape did not
only killed Dumbledore to adhere to the
conditions of the vow but also to
appease Dumbledore and spare Malfoy from
having to endure the act of murder which
Dumbledore felt would permanently affect
Draco in the event that a ritual wizard
is unable to honor the promise that
they've made with them breakable vow
they will die this is the ultimate
consequence and that is of course white
is deemed unbreakable you are stuck with
what you've promised until you either
act on said promise or die as far as I
know there is no other way of getting
out of an unbreakable vow another known
instance in which an unbreakable vow was
mentioned at Harry Potter was when Fred
and George Weasley attempted to coerce
event five-year-old Ron into one it is
said that Fred and George were ready to
perform the vow when their father Arthur
Weasley caught
this is the only instance in which
Arthur Weasley
is said to have gotten as angry as his
wife Molly I had previously thought that
perhaps the unbreakable vow was advanced
magic as it is not used often in Harry
Potter however if a very young Fred and
George are beat powerful Wizards could
perform the spell then I don't think
it's quite as complicated as one might
think
I was wondered why it wasn't used more I
would have thought that it could have
been an amazing way of ensuring that
someone is trustworthy
perhaps Hogwarts could have used it to
ensure that new professors weren't
actually evil this could have eliminated
potential issues with people like
Quirrell and Barty Crouch jr. what do
you guys think how would you have liked
to have seen the unbreakable values in
Harry Potter let me know down in the
comment section below
and remember help will always be given
at Hogwarts to those who deserve it
[Music]
you